the home of the University of Idaho has
been shaken up by the deaths of four
students and people there still know
very little about how or why the victims
were killed the bodies of three women
and one man all 21 or under were found
together over the weekend police say
that they have released all the
information that they can at this time
without jeopardizing their investigation
but they insist there is no wider threat
to the public yet there have still been
no arrest and there are still a lot of
unanswered questions in this case
Jonathan Vigliotti has been following
this story
police in the city of Moscow say the
four University of Idaho students who
were killed in this home across the
street from campus Sunday were victims
of a targeted attack investigators
believe a quote edged weapon such as a
knife was used although no weapon was
recovered from the scene this is a
pretty dramatic situation for our Campus
Community the victims appeared to have
been close friends on the same day they
were killed Kaylee gonsalves posted this
picture showing all four students
smiling while posing together one lucky
girl to be surrounded by these people
every day she wrote Zanna kernodle
posted this loving message about Ethan
Chapin saying life is so much better
with you in it this morning their
families are grieving their loss zanna's
sister Jasmine kernodle telling CBS News
Zanna was so positive funny and was
loved by everyone who met her my family
and I are at a lot of words confused and
anxiously waiting for updates on the
investigation the murders were called a
crime of passion by the mayor but police
have not offered a potential motive for
a suspect well there was a lot of blood
when asked Tuesday about the possibility
of a murder-suicide the County coroner
was adamant someone else was responsible
now there are four homicides authorities
say there is no imminent threat to the
community at large a lot of people left
last night but many front-end students
have decided to go on Thanksgiving break
a week early my mom has called me every
single hour they want me to come home if
I don't feel safe for CBS mornings I'm
Jonathan Vigliotti
it's very troubling authorities clearly
know something but it's hard to ask
people to be patient when you have four
people dead and no one can understand
that parent calling four times a day
every hour yeah you're right about that
yeah